-♪ Drop it in, drop it in,
d-d-d-drop it in ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Dalvin, you're named
NFC Offensive
Player of the Week today.
How do you feel about that?
-Great. Um, give all the credit
to the O line up front,
receivers, tight ends,
just going out there
and just working hard.
And I run yards like Swiss
chard, so that's what it is.
-What is your favorite part
about being a receiver?
Is it catching touchdown passes?
Is it your dance celebrations?
-Uh, I believe catching
the touchdown passes,
'cause, you know,
they're like Pokémon to me.
I got to have them all.
-What makes that connection
with you guys
on that particular throw so
difficult for anybody to defend?
-Yeah, I mean, it's like
a saying my mom used to say.
"It must be maple syrup, because
butter don't drizzle like that."
-Ryan, do you stick with
the finger-roll celebration
or do you change it up?
-You know,
I think I got to stick with it.
You know, I think through
the whole process I learned
that's why you call them
touchdowns and not touch-ups.
-But again, I mean, myself, you
know, I'm looking forward to it.
You know, again, you know,
call me Old Fashioned.
You know, like, literally.
I mean it.
Call me Old Fashioned.
That's my new nickname.
-I mean, you know,
on the team right now,
they call me Old Fashioned.
You know, I mean it.
You know, that's my new
nickname, Old Fashioned.
-Maybe even I'll bring that up
and put that in his ear
a little bit.
You know, sometimes you got to
throw the sauce at your boss.
-Well, you know,
there's not a week that goes by
where Coach Reid
isn't gonna on you, man.
That's his job, you know?
Sometimes
you just got to be like,
"Take it easy,
RollerCoaster Tycoon."
You know what I mean?
-What you mom said is
a quote that
I am not familiar with.
Can you elaborate
a little more on that?
-Syrup drizzles.
You got to make that play.
Uh, a stick of butter --
it's a block.
You got to put that
in the microwave to melt it.
That just takes too long.
You got to make
that play right away, baby,
and that's why, you know, that's
why I'm like the maple syrup.
That's why she used to
always say that
'cause I'm quick with it.
I just drizzle
all over the place.
[ Chuckles ]
-Thank you so much.
-No problem. Thank you.